[Música]
en ucrania los niños han pagado un alto
precio durante la guerra
219 menores han fallecido hasta la fecha
según la fiscalía general ucraniana y
algunos hospitales infantiles han sido
objeto de ataques tenemos reporte desde
el hospital de mico life afectado por
los ataques rusos
por segunda vez en 6 años el líder
supremo de los talibanes habló frente a
los fieles en la ciudad de kandahar en
el sur de afganistán mientras celebraban
el aid al-fitr o la ruptura del ayuno
luego del mes sagrado del ramadán el
líder talibán felicitó a los zánganos
por su éxito tras la toma del poder en
agosto de 2021
países de latinoamérica comenzaron a
relajar sus medidas anti kobe 19 chile
reabrió varias de sus fronteras
terrestres colombia eliminó el uso
obligatorio del tapabocas en interiores
y perú hizo lo propio en exteriores en
algunas de sus regiones
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos esta emisión en
ucrania donde los niños han pagado un
alto precio durante la guerra
219 menores han fallecido hasta la fecha
según la fiscalía general ucraniana y
algunos hospitales infantiles han sido
alcanzados por los bombardeos de las
tropas rusas entre ellos el de mico life
que visitaron nuestros enviados
especiales catalina gómez ángel y mikel
konaté
el doctor alexander muestra lugar donde
cayó una de las 13 bombas que impactaron
el hospital que dirige
nuestro caso en ese lado del hospital la
otra en el otro y una más en lo profundo
del jardín en el techo y otras más
explotaron en los alrededores
las autoridades ucranianas han
denunciado que desde el comienzo de la
guerra las fuerzas rusas han atacado
sistemáticamente hospitales
especialmente donde hay presencia de
niños este está en la población de
mykolaiv en el sur del país y fue
atacado el pasado 4 de abril y quedan
muestras de esos ataques en cada una de
estas ventanas y en la fachada del
edificio
saben que esto es un hospital infantil
donde no hay militares
pero hay niños heridos
el fiscal general ucraniano asegura que
219 niños han muerto desde el comienzo
de la guerra y 404 han quedado heridos
el 98% de los niños que llegan a este
hospital lo hacen en condiciones de
extrema gravedad
los doctores dicen que al menos 30 niños
han llegado al hospital heridos por
ataques de las fuerzas rusas pero
también nos dicen que no solamente tiene
que ver con ataques específicos que la
guerra ha pasado a permear lo todo que
el estrés de la sociedad es bastante
grande por ejemplo este pequeño que está
aquí al lado está quemado su casa se
incendió viene de una familia numerosa y
los niños están tan estresados que
muchas veces hacen cosas inesperadas y
este otro joven que está a mis espaldas
y va en una moto muy rápido y se
accidentó
la vida no solamente ha cambiado para
los niños sino también para el personal
médico muchos de ellos viven
permanentemente en el hospital
no
[Música]
lo más difícil es cuando los niños
llegan heridos de muerte
carlos a metros y no se les puede salvar
la vida 'teníamos responder
para doctores como julia es difícil
manejar el dolor que se ha ido
acumulando con el paso de los días con
una selección de ocho jóvenes atletas
ucranianos que escaparon de ucrania por
la guerra para ir al vania se niega a
dejar que la angustia y la ansiedad de
su país natal afecten a su éxito
deportivo mientras intensifican su
entrenamiento para llevar el orgullo a
ucrania el viaje fue financiado por el
comité olímpico ucraniano el gobierno
local de albania en el bazán se ha hecho
cargo de todo desde el alojamiento hasta
el transporte y la seguridad
volvemos la mirada hacia la comunidad
musulmana que el primero de mayo vivió
el final del mes sagrado del ramadán en
marruecos desde la mezquita de los
omeyas en rabat miembros del ministerio
de asuntos islámicos observaron la caída
del sol y la salida de la luna creciente
que marca el inicio de la fiesta del eid
al-fitr o de la ruptura del ayuno y del
shawal el décimo mes del calendario
lunar islámico en indonesia el país con
mayor número de musulmanes del mundo los
fieles celebraron el aís con rezos
multitudinarios en afganistán se celebró
por primera vez esta fiesta desde la
llegada de los talibanes al poder allí
hubo celebraciones multitudinarias en la
región de kandahar y en mali la
violencia que azota al país no impidió
que cientos de fieles se reunieran en la
gran mezquita de bamako
por segunda vez en 6 años el líder
supremo de los talibanes habló frente a
los fieles en la ciudad de kandahar en
el sur de afganistán mientras muchos
celebraban el eid al-fitr en su
aparición felicitó a los afganos por su
éxito tras la toma de poder por parte de
los talibanes en agosto de 2021 y dijo a
la multitud que los talibanes han
logrado la libertad y la seguridad en el
país
en un momento raro e inesperado el líder
supremo de afganistán habló en la
mezquita de édgar el último día del
ramadán
durante su discurso se mantuvo de
espaldas a la multitud las autoridades
prohibieron las grabaciones y que los
periodistas se acercaran a él
[Música]
es su segunda aparición pública desde
que se convirtió en líder talibán hace
seis años
estoy tan feliz que no puedo ni
describir lo son y orar con el líder
supremo escuchar su voz y verlo
juro que estoy tan feliz que llore
cuando escuche su voz tuve dos sueños en
mi vida el primero fue ver el regreso
del emirato islámico y el segundo fue
ver a nuestro líder de la discreción del
líder supremo ha dado lugar a rumores en
varias ocasiones algunos referidos a su
verdadera capacidad de influencia dentro
del emirato islámico y otros a
preocupaciones sobre su salud durante su
pronunciamiento felicitó a los fieles
por el regreso de la seguridad al país
desde que los talibanes tomaron el
control en agosto pasado
a pesar que el número de ataques se
redujo en todo afganistán este ramadán
ha sido particularmente letal para el
país varios ataques han afectado a la
minoría chiíta y también una mezquita
sunita donde se realizaba una ceremonia
sufí varios de estos ataques han sido
reivindicados por el grupo estado
islámico
en kabul durante el último día del mes
sagrado la asistencia a las mezquitas ha
sido menor de lo habitual debido al
temor de nuevos ataques
el jefe de la junta militar que dirige
guinea conakry tras el golpe de estado
de 2021 propuso una transición de tres
años y tres meses para entregar el poder
a un gobierno civil el coronel mamá de
don bullaque dirige la junta militar
aseguró que se trata de una propuesta
consensuada que aún debe ser aprobada
por el consejo nacional de la transición
un parlamento provisional compuesto por
81 miembros de partidos políticos grupos
de la sociedad civil sindicatos
patronales y fuerzas de seguridad del
país
y acabamos con noticias de kobe 19 en la
región de américa latina donde varios
países han relajado sus restricciones en
chile fueron reabiertas la mayor parte
de las fronteras terrestres cerradas
desde abril de 2021 en colombia desde
este primero de mayo dejó de ser
obligatorio el uso del tapabocas en
interiores en lugares donde el 70% de la
población esté ya vacunada y al menos el
40% tenga la dosis de refuerzo en perú
las provincias de ica callao ancash lima
metropolitana y lima vivieron su primer
día sin tapabocas en las calles desde
que comenzara la pandemia en este país
solamente las provincias con más del 80%
de su población mayor de 60 años
vacunada con la tercera dosis y más del
80 por ciento con la segunda en mayores
de 12 años pueden aprovechar esta
relajación de medidas anteriormente
hablamos con carlos álvarez médico
infectólogo y coordinador de estudios de
kobe 19 de la organización mundial de la
salud para colombia le pudimos preguntar
en qué punto de la pandemia se encuentra
la región y si podría ser de su final
bueno creo que vamos en un punto en el
que ha estabilizado la circulación del
virus en la región eso significa que
estamos teniendo una baja transmisión
obviamente no es que el virus se haya
ido sino que sencillamente al tener un
número importante de personas que ya se
han vacunado y que adicionalmente
también puedan haberse recuperado el 19
pues hace que en esta región tengamos lo
que estamos cerca a una inmunidad
poblacional pues estamos hablando de
empezar a pasar a una fase diferente y
eso podría ser el comienzo de lo que se
llama técnicamente una fase endémica que
si bien es cierto hay que decir que en
esta fase se estabiliza la circulación
del virus no significa que no pueden
haber picos epidémicos pero ya de una
manera más controlada que no van a
sobrepasar el sistema sanitario
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a france 24
[Música]